يوم دام في مخيم الجن شهداء وجرحى
بالعشرات ودمار خلفه جنود الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي في اقتحام وصف بالاوسع والاعنا
في منذر اجتياح الكبير عام 2002 يقول
الجيش الاحتلال ان معلومات استخباراتيه
دلته على مكان وجود ثلاثه من المطلوبين
واطلق صواريخ مضاده للدروع صوبهم وسرعان
ما وقع اشتباك مسلح بين جنود الاحتلال
ومقاومين اخرين وصلوا الى المكان
2002 حضرت معركه 2002 بس زي اليوم
اعقل احتلال دخول فرق الاسعاف الى المخيم
وانتشال الجرحى والشهداء يتحدث شهود عيان
عن ترويع الناس والاعتداء على ممتلكاتهم
وسحقي مركباتهم وهم داخلها في سلوك
الانتقام
كحمايه مؤسسه
بالسيارات وطحلب
خرج الناس في وداع الشهداء ونددت الفصائل
الفلسطينيه كافه بما سمته جرائم الاحتلال
وهو استنكار لم يخلو من توجيه لهم للمجتمع
الدولي على صمته حيل ما يجري في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه
[موسيقى]
المنافق العدد الكبير من الشهداء والجرحى
يعكس في نظر الفلسطينيين نجاح حكومه
اليمين التي تتعامل مع الوضع الامني
بشراسه لارضاء خلفائها من اقصى اليمين
المتطرف وهو من شانه ان يضع الاراضي
الفلسطينيه المحتله على شفا الفجار كبير
منذ شهور يقمع الاحتلال الاسرائيليون
الفلسطينيين بالحديد والنار وكل ما صعد من
عمليات الدم والاعتقالي والقتل يقول
الفلسطينيون انه سيجدوا امامه شعبان لا
يخشى الموجهه ويصر على المقاومه